pre-crime it's not just in Minority
Report scientists have found a way to
predict whether convicted criminals are
going to commit another crime it's a
little technical here but basically they
scan the anterior cingulate cortex the
ACC in 96 prisoners and the area in the
brain that's associated with
decision-making they found often was
smaller and they followed these convicts
for about four years thus finding out
that many of them did cause repeat
crimes so my question to you guys broad
topic here is everything that we've ever
seen in science fiction going to destroy
us because this is Minority Report one
of my favorite movies and are we all
going to suffer from science fiction and
everything that has been in every mouth
wouldn't have it any other way no no um
hey science fiction writers saw this
stuff and were able to write about it
because they saw it as a possibility I
mean this is Clockwork Orange to a tee I
mean Anthony Burgess that's what it is
you know trying to can we figure out how
to you know impact free will enough when
free will runs afoul to stop crimes from
being committed and that movie obviously
had a lot to say on the topic and not
everything was you know crystal not a
lot of crystal clear conclusions but hey
I think and I'm not an alarmist about
like you know about technology and
everyone bitching that some you know
Mark Zuckerberg owns them because he
knows that they purchase something off
but no bows yeah um good luck yeah thank
you uh but um this starts to concern me
because you could there's so many other
factors and so much other data that you
could use to correlate you know a
production for crime and you think about
it and one thing that a lot of people
never touch on is that crime has gone
down a lot over the last 20 years or so
so the same factors that were you know
that were at play 20 years ago are at
play now and some of those people didn't
commit crimes so how do you reconcile
that and how do you whatever solution
that they're going to generate from this
new data and being able to predict this
how I trying to apply it and without
completely destructive effects I
couldn't
imagine yeah so where do you think this
puts the nature versus nurture argument
if you're just predisposed to be a
criminal than is at it then should we be
locking people up no I think I mean even
the study alone if you know if when you
continue to read into it there's some
links to just the in-depth analysis of
the study and of course you know at the
end of it even though that they did find
I think was almost you know double the
amount of the inmates with like the low
activity of that part of the brain for
like the actions and decision-making
they did find that that there was other
variables in place too of course this
wasn't a perfect study but they saw it
could be contributed to too much
caffeine it could be like loose
variables and then of course there's the
nature versus nurture did they grow up
in poverty so there's so many variables
it would take a really long time in a
whole lot more science to really break
into that study and make sure that you
know that it is perfect variable free
before they can implement this into the
prison system and aren't there a ton of
just sociological things such as or
socio-economic things such as if you
grew up horror and we're given a worse
diet and had less nutrition that that
does affect your development and your
brain and all that is it specifically
decision making that's the target that's
supposed to equal future in crime well
what for dig what part of your very much
I from commanding I make very bad
decisions but they don't lead they don't
lead to you know that Porter mentality
yeah like my position on the porn clips
maybe I should have chosen the other way
but that doesn't mean I'm will go out
and hold somebody up actually speaking
of the poor they haven't they proven
that when you're watching porn like a
certain part of your brain actually is
shrinking like it's actually feeding
endorphins or something and yeah he lost
his train of thought as we were as we
were saying um all that porn clearly um
yeah a lot they're not that I'm a
neuroscientist even though that's how I
got on the show by telling you that well
yeah um it says neuroscience uh yeah
yeah there's certain there's certain
parts of the brain they're just
associated with pleasure and stimulation
you know aggression and they cover it
that's really interesting that they
cover a lot of the same ground between
violence and sex yeah and you know it's
probably of an indictment of the entire
male gender that those are the things
that that kind of shape our goals but
we'll just push that to the side no
there won't no women having poor
decision criminal thoughts is that what
women are excluded Oh riveter totally i
actually i would that would be very very
interesting that would be interesting to
know whether I really there was actually
some data there that was worth talking
about i mean there's no this this extra
study yeah there's nothing there really
there that that makes this study any
more sophisticated than just like cons
then didn't we didn't we get a word like
fern ology was proven wrong expression
point right like you'd be a girl world
you can't you can't you can't tell by
the shape of someone's head whether or
not they're a bad egg is that right well
it's interesting i think i thought well
what not what's nothing us on that what
are you what i thought was interesting
about the study because for the people
that they did follow the four years
after yeah and they were able to see and
yes there were other variables like i
say there were the caffeine like random
variables that could have contributed to
it but in the end they did see that the
people that were reoffending did have
significantly less activity within that
area of action and decision-making so if
they could perfect eight years down the
road it could be 20 years whatever i
think that would be incredible like i
said before carefully speaking if it was
variable free to be able to see which
criminals are going to reoffend in which
aren't that would be an ideal situation
bonobos calm is the official outfitter
of the Ruben report use code trr 20 to
get this shirt and these jeans